on retrouve ce soir à londres jean
boivin directeur de l'institut blackrock
investment et ancien sous-gouverneur à
la banque du canada
bonsoir monsieur beauvais bonjour
monsieur fillion si je vous demandais
d'abord deux qualifiés la crise
économique que nous vivons en ce moment
par rapport à ce qu'on a déjà vécu
qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire je
dirais d'avoir que c'est sans précédent
en termes de l'impact que ça leur a à
court terme
on parle de ralentissement pas de
freiner l'économie en fait c'est parce
qu'on ralentissement freinage délibéré
et donc dans l'est dans les mois et
trimestres sont présents on va avoir une
belle si une contraction de l'économie
sans précédente donc ça c'est une façon
de qualifier la situation
l'autre point important par contre c'est
que les comparaisons typique en termes
de cycle économique je crois ne
s'applique pas ce qu'on vit présentement
il n'ya pas vraiment de barème ou de
parallèles historiques
on peut faire référence on parle là la
meilleure comparaison c'est un désastre
naturel qui qui décontracté l'activité
économique de façon très accentués et là
le virus son impact est très très proche
de ce genre de phénomène va donc ça
implique de deux éléments mais une chose
c'est que n'est pas compétent mais sans
précédent mais on le sait que ça va
arriver parce qu'on est tous en train
d'y contribuer ce ralentissement
économique là et donc les informations
qu'ils qui viennent à mesure des jours
et des semaines sur l'activité
économique est moins importante qu'elle
est peut-être dans un cycle habituel en
tome 2 des thèmes de ce qui se passe
donc c'est très inédit se quitter ni dit
également et on va le voir dans un
graphique que vous avez préparé
c'est la très forte hausse de
l'intervention de la réserve fédérale
qui a racheté notamment beaucoup
d'obligations là on voit que en 2008
on est en aveux bilan des actifs de
réserve fédérale de près de 1000
milliards qui est monté à 35 105 mille
milliards en 2014 mais qui s'en va
selon vos projections à plus de onze
mille milliards cette année nous entende
de révolution en termes des politiques
macroéconomiques
qui ont été mises en place globalement
et seulement dans le l'espace de
quelques semaines comme le graphique le
montre ce qui a été décidé exemple à
seulement aux états unis et d'une
ampleur d'une hauteur de grandeur que ce
qu'on a vu en ensemble de la gestion de
la crise de 2007 2008 donc l'ensemble
des mesures qui ont été prises entre
2007 et 2014 pour gérer la crise
financière est ce qu'on parle même pas
ce qu'il était mis en place en fait mis
en marche cette année auprès de la fed
donc ça c'est juste en termes de
l'ampleur et l'eau partie importante de
révolution ici c'est que non seulement
remise en place des mesures qui avaient
été mises en place auparavant
innover et l'innovation et sans
précédent dont on parle de mesure une
grosse partie de cette augmentation là
qu'on voit qui en fait des mesures qui
ont un aspect d'aller plus directement
peut procurer des liquidités ou une
entité qui en ont besoin dans l'économie
et de moins se reposer sur le mécanisme
de transmission
c'est un secteur financier et donc ça
aussi c'est inédit ça soulève un
ensemble de questions qui on va prendre
des mois des années a assez donné
l'emploi l'application mais c'est
effectivement sans précédent une
révolution à la fois en termes de
grandeur mais aussi du type de mesures
qui ont été mises en place quand on
regarde par ailleurs la stimulation
fiscale des gouvernements au fil du
temps en 2020 etats unis europe
zone euro japon chez nous on est presque
6% du pib en termes de valeur de
stimulation fiscale
en 2009 on n'était même pas 2 % du pib
encore là c'est c'est une autre
révolution ça c'est l'augmentation des
dépenses budgétaires et des déficits
budgétaires qui vont en découler qui ont
été décidés encore une fois au cours de
quelques semaines et est sans précédent
en période de paix mais contre les
comparaisons qu'on devrait devrait
prendre eux mêmes en de grandeur sont
durant la deuxième guerre mondiale aux
états unis certainement donc c'est
effectivement d'une ampleur énorme et je
pense que ça ramène un point important
pour boucler la boucle avec le point de
départ d'une conversation qui est que la
contraction que dont on vit est sans
précédent
on y participe on sait ce qui arrive
l'impact est énorme à court terme mais
d'autre part ce qui va être important
pour les marchés financiers pour le
bien-être de l'économie à plus long
terme c'est l'impact cumulatif à travers
le temps et dans la mesure où on est
capable d'empêcher la crise économique
de se transformer en crise financière on
peut arriver en bout de ligne
quand même on est un coût économique qui
va du nord de grade comme à l'intérieur
lorsqu'on a vu en 2008 parce qu'en 2008
ça s'est étendu sur dix ans et c'est un
manque à gagner qui est énorme et c'est
là que les politiques sans précédent
dont on vient de mentionner joue peuvent
pas jouer vont jouer un rôle énorme si
on arrive effectivement à empêcher une
crise financière
on pourrait arriver quand même en bout
de ligne une situation qui est moins
profond c'est intéressant peut-être même
plus rassurant d'entendre cela jusqu'à
un certain point est-ce que des risques
d'inflation d'inflation importante à ce
stade si je pense pas que c'est une
provocation pour pour pour personne et
certainement pas pour les marchés
financiers c'est un rappel pour les
décideurs de politiques économiques qui
est l'inflation va très court terme je
pense basse et pousser encore plus à la
base contre x
alors que l'on connaît ensuite donc mais
on suit donc la grande question c'est
peut-être pas cette année ou l'an
prochain mais si on pendant qu'ils ont à
5,5 à une augmentation des déficits
budgétaires donc une fois qu ici
effectivement une reprise économique et
un rebond on va se retrouver avec un
stimulus en place qui est énorme et
l'assouplissement monétaire et sans
précédent comme je le mentionnais et non
seulement il est sans précédent mais il
ya un élément de coordination et piscine
ou explicite entre la politique
monétaire et budgétaire qui fait en
sorte que ça va peut-être pas être aussi
facile de resserrer la politique
monétaire lorsque les pressions
inflationnistes manifester et dans ce
contexte là il les risques d'inflation à
moyen terme sont peut-être un peu plus à
la hausse étant de ce qui était mise en
place bien jean boivin à londres merci
beaucoup je vous remercie